salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui je
voulais faire une vidéo pour débloquer
un argument qu'on entend souvent dans la
bouche des pro russe pour justifier
l'invasion de l'ukraine par vladimir
poutine les pro-russes nous disent que
poutine est intervenu pour notamment
stoppez le génocide en cours dans le
dôme basse l'est séparatistes et à
l'appui de cet argument nous cite
souvent le chiffre de 13 mille 14000
voire quinze mille
ukrainien russophone massacrées depuis
le début de l'insurrection séparatiste
en 2014
alors qu'en est il et d'où vient ce
chiffre ce chiffre de 13 mille personnes
est en fait tiré d'un rapport de l'onu
qui se cherchaient à
documenter où en est elle à la guerre
dans le donbass et ce rapport conclut
qu'il ya eu au total treize mille
victimes depuis 2014 sachant que c'est
treize mille victimes ne sont pas des
civils mais se répartit comme suit trois
mille trois cents civils donc du donbass
russophone 4500 militaires loyalistes
ukrainien et 5500 militaire séparatiste
de plus ses 3300 victimes civiles ont
pour la plupart à 90% été tuées pendant
les deux premières années de la guerre
en 2014 et 2015 et ensuite on tombe à
100 voire même 50 civils tués par an
alors peut-on parler de génocide avec de
tels chiffres sachant que la région du
donbass au total compte 6 2 millions de
personnes et bien pour le savoir il faut
comparer avec des génocides qui ont été
documentés historiquement pour rester en
ukraine lors de l'invasion nazie
eh bien les nazis et leurs supplétifs
nationalistes ukrainiens ont massacré
tous les juifs qui pouvait trouver en
ukraine et cela donnait notamment le
massacre de babi yar qui sur deux jours
a vu périr 33 mille juifs soit en
moyenne seize mille cinq cents par jour
à comparer donc avec les 3000 civils qui
ont péri dans cette gare du donbass
depuis 2014 autre exemple de génocide
plus près de nous historiquement est un
petit peu plus loin géographiquement le
massacre des tutsis par les hutus au
rwanda en 1994
ce génocide a duré une centaine de jours
et a fait huit cent mille morts c'est à
dire huit mille morts par jour
encore une fois à comparer avec les 3000
morts depuis huit ans dans une guerre
conventionnelle
on peut aussi parler du massacre pour
rester un peu en thématiques avec la
russie le massacre des officiers
polonais suite à l'invasion de la
pologne par les nazis et les soviétiques
avec notamment le massacre de katyn
pendant lequel les soviétiques en six
semaines ont massacré 4400 officiers
polonais
en six semaines les soviétiques ont donc
massacrer plus que la guerre du donbass
a fait deux morts en huit ans
on peut voir que clairement aux dents
place n'y a pas aujourd'hui de génocide
un génocide c'est plutôt non pas
quelques centaines de personnes par an
est plutôt quelques milliers par jour
on peut aussi comparer ces chiffres du
donbass avec d'autres guerres pour voir
s'il s'agit de guerre de haute ou de
basse intensité par exemple avec la
guerre de bosnie au milieu des années 90
qui a opposé trois ethnies les serbes
les bosniaques et les croates
sur un territoire donc la bosnie
herzégovine qui avait une population
initiale de 4 5 millions de personnes au
cours de la guerre qui a duré quasiment
quatre ans vous avez eu au total cent
mille morts dont un tiers de ces îles à
peu près donc trente cinq mille civils
en quatre ans encore une fois à comparer
aux 3000 morts en luttant d'une ombre
basse d'ailleurs si on fait un petit
produit en croix pour voir
ce qu'aurait donné la guerre du donbass
si elle avait eu la même intensité que
la guerre de bosnie est avec en fonction
de la durée et en fonction de la taille
de la population et bien c'est comme si
haut dans de basses en mi temps on
aurait on aurait eu et bien à peu près
300 mille morts au total dont 75 mille à
cent mille civils très clairement avec
3300 morts on est très loin du compte
donc non dans le donbass il n'y a pas de
génocide et on est sur une guerre qui de
plus est de relativement basse intensité
donc amis pro russe merci et bien de
d'éviter ce genre d'arguments qui non
seulement est totalement inepte d'un
point de vue des chiffres mais en plus
est insultant pour les peuples qui eux
ont réellement connu des génocides
bref j'espère que cette vidéo de mise au
point vous aura intéressé si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à partager et à vous
abonner à la chaîne et sur ce je vous
dis à la prochaine